bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
dans file echo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de cette émission des retraités
yvelinois ont manifesté mardi à
versailles nous entendrons leurs
revendications
à deux mois de la trêve hivernale nous
sommes allés dans une structure
d'accueil à versailles encore une
solution à moyen terme pour les
résidents alors que les structures
d'urgence sont saturés et puis leur la
drh pardon vous connaissez ce sigle les
ressources humaines nous verrons comment
leur gestion s'est adapté à notre
société avec notre dossier de la semaine
puis enfin nous parlerons automobile
avec notre invité dominique mocka re
bonsoir oui chef vous êtes aujourd'hui
la tête du groupe à l'infini vous
souhaitez développer les voitures
électriques et l'autopartage nous
reviendrons sur votre parcours et le
développement de votre quatre
entreprises dans un instant on passe
avant cela aux actualités économiques de
la semaine
je vous le disais dans les titres les
retraités illinois sont en colère mardi
à l'appel de la cgt une manifestation
était organisée devant la préfecture de
versailles ils estiment que leur
situation se dégrade notamment en ce qui
concerne l'accès aux soins yolaine
thorez jonathan vieux-mans ils viennent
d'être reçus par le préfet des retraités
vinoy de la cgt se sont rassemblés ce
matin à versailles pour crier leur
mécontentement
nous avons reporté le mal vivre au
traité aujourd'hui
c'est l'union confédérale des retraités
cgt qui a lancé cette campagne au niveau
national parmi les nombreux sujets qui
fâchent le report de la revalorisation
des pensions de retraite au 1er octobre
l'accès aux soins de plus en plus
difficile mais pas seulement on estime
que depuis 93 devoir d'achat de
retraites a été diminuée de 20 % donc
partant de là on a vécu aussi les
franchises santé
aujourd'hui on vit là la hausse de la
tva on est taxé à 0 3% pour la casa et
le pour l'aide à l'autonomie si
retraités en colère estime aussi qu'il
joue un rôle important au sein de la
société
s'il n'existait pas s'il a arrêté
aujourd'hui leur activité bénévole dans
la société il ya beaucoup de gens qui
sera encore plus en difficulté les
associations etc donc on n'est pas que
des bouches à nourrir
improductives dans le département des
yvelines plus de 1500 cartes pétitions
déjà été signé elles seront déposées à
l'elysée ce jeudi 20 février par une
délégation représentant les huit
départements de l'île de france
le samu social à tire la sonnette
d'alarmé à deux mois de la fin de la
trêve hivernale les demandes
d'hébergement d'urgence ou sont en
hausse les appels au 115 ont augmenté de
5% en janvier ils ont même augmenté de
11 % concernant les femmes à versailles
une structure existe depuis 20 ans et
accueille neuf résidents pour une durée
maximum d'un an le bétel ne propose pas
d'hébergement d'urgence et n'est ouvert
qu'aux hommes mais ici les résidents
construisent un projet de réinsertion
pour ne plus jamais tomber dans la rue
yolaine thorez jonathan littman
victoire est arrivé au bethel il y a
quelques jours sans emploi expulsé de
son logement cela faisait un an qu'il
dormait dans des voitures ou des garages
c'est finalement son assistante sociale
qui l'a orienté vers cette structure
d'accueil pour homme en difficulté logés
blanchis et nourrit pour seulement 250
euros par mois il peut mener son projet
de réinsertion dans de bonnes conditions
déjà vous avez un toit êtes en sécurité
vous pouvez vous alimentez
et puis ensuite
allé en otage quotidienne qui
aujourd'hui dans mon cas est de
rechercher un emploi très rapidement
trouver un emploi rapidement
ancien technicien victor souhaite
aujourd'hui se réorienter vers
l'humanitaire comme lui ils sont neuf à
pouvoir bénéficier de cet accueil un
accueil exclusivement réservé aux hommes
seuls souvent passer dans la rue ayant
la volonté de sortir de leur situation
le temps d'un an maximum chacun dispose
d'une chambre individuelle de la cuisine
de la salle de bains et du salon commun
il y a aussi des règles à respecter et
dans ces règles là c'est à dire qu'ils
ont ce qu'on appelle là bas
un
planning hebdomadaire et chacun des
tâches pensionnat qui va être référent
pour préparer à manger la semaine il y
en a un qui va laver le salon nous
sommes là nous qui veulent la laddh le
couloir le premier étage et c'est chacun
a des admissions à respecter
subventionnés en majeure partie par la
direction départementale de la cohésion
sociale des yvelines le bétel fait
partie de l'association sos accueil qui
mène plusieurs actions en 2013 sur les
26 résidents reçu ici dix d'entre eux
ont trouvé un logement et un emploi
souvent les autres retournent dans leurs
familles quittent la région où sont
réorientés vers d'autres structures
nous l'apprenions la semaine dernière un
ingénieur de 60 ans s'est suicidé le 12
février sur son lieu de travail
l'entreprise dassault systèmes à vélizy
villacoublay
l'homme a sauté du cinquième étage une
enquête est toujours en cours mais
d'après les premiers éléments de ce
drame il serait lié à des problèmes
personnels pour rappel dassault systèmes
est une filiale du groupe marcel
dassault elle a été créée en 1981 pour
développer des logiciels de conception
en 3d aujourd'hui elle propose ses
services aux entreprises industrielles
notamment en leur fournissant des
visions 3d du cycle de vie de leurs
produits
en 2013 elle affiché un chiffre
d'affaires de 2,06 milliards d'euros
elle emploie près de 10000
collaborateurs dont 2500 à vélizy
gary hansen c'est un ancien sportif de
haut niveau sa passion le vélo à 30 ans
il a réussi avec brio une reconversion
dans le e-commerce il a fondé il ya cinq
ans une société spécialisée dans la
vente de pièces détachées de vélo
désormais avec 20 millions de chiffre
d'affaires il veut s'exporter à
l'étranger un reportage signé anthony
rech et patrick jacques de dixmude
quand on voit gary marché dans les
allées de son stock on n'imaginerait pas
une seule seconde que dix ans plus tôt
ce compétiteur de bt&t au niveau
national et européen je suis tel ur de
man lors d'un entraînement je suis cassé
la colonne vertébrale j'ai été
immobilisé un peu plus d'un an j'ai
découvert l'internet et le e-commerce à
ce moment là parce que je pouvais plus
bouger et
de ma passion en fait j'essaie
transposer ça sur un modèle commercial
donc le e-commerce et l'aventuré n'est
en mai 2008 donc autour du vélo c'est
donc de son lit que gary se lance dans
la vente de pièces détachées accessoires
pour vélos et donne naissance à ault
rixe avec seulement 6000 euros six mille
c'est aussi le nombre de mètres carrés
sur lesquels est désormais installé son
entreprise
aujourd'hui hall tricks et 45 salariés
dix sept mille références en stock et un
chiffre d'affaires en 2013 de 20
millions d'euros à 30 ans gary compte
bien passer au braquet supérieur la
majeure partie de l'activité est
concentrée sur la france aujourd'hui est
le challenge pour 2014 ces deux d'avancé
sur des pays comme le portugal l'espagne
l'italie où il ya peu de sites internet
dans le vélo aujourd'hui et pour autant
beaucoup de pratiquants consécration
pour l'entreprise de gary après le
vélodrome nationale hall trick sera
partenaire d'aso pour le tout premier
rock paris où se donneront rendez-vous
des milliers de vététistes du 28 au 30
mars prochain à mantes la jolie
et on enchaîne tout de suite avec un
autre entrepreneur yvelinois dominique
mot car dans l'entretien
dominique mocka re bonjour vous êtes à
la tête du groupe automobile à l'infini
qui regroupe aujourd'hui quatre
entreprises alors ça fait 20 ans que le
groupe existe on reviendra dans un
enfant sur son évolution mais la
nouveauté c'est la sortie prochaine de
votre premier véhicule en puisque en
2013 un constructeur a rejoint votre
groupe vous êtes aujourd'hui la tête de
jdm constructeur de voitures sans permis
comment sera cette nouvelle voiture
alors il s'appelle déjà xeos donc avec
ces hausses elle évoque déjà par sa
forme que je pense que vous verrez tout
à l'heure à l'écran
une image de modernité une image qui
n'évoque plus en fin de compte la petite
voiture mais au contraire une voiture
qui qui se veut élégante qui faisait qui
se veut communicants qui se veut être un
porte-drapeau du groupe à l'infini et 7
jdm automobile doit effectivement faire
décoller l'ensemble du groupe avec des
perspectives très intéressantes qui vont
être dans tout l'ensemble des
perspectives du groupe sur la voiture
communicante alors on voit à l'image
votre voiture est incassable ouais alors
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui m'a fut arrêté
parce que depuis un certain temps je
suis dans la plateforme la filière
automobile où l'on parle des deux litres
aux cent et c'est vrai que dans cette
plateforme de filière automobile et de
litres au cent ou tout le monde de tous
les constructeurs en tout cas à se
mettre d'accord pour dire la voiture
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui
en tôle emboutie pesant une tonne 5 pour
transporter les gens qui pèse entre 60 à
80 kg c'est vrai qu'il ya une
disproportion est donc pour arriver à
faire du moins 2 litres au cent qui
aujourd'hui le grand mot d'ordre il va
falloir baisser de 50 % le poids et donc
le poids ça peut plus être avec de la
tôle donc ça remet tout en cause tout
process de fabrication
il a accès aux dons qui vient de sortir
est une voiture qui est fait en
matériaux composites allégé avec des
matériaux proche d'eux la compétition la
lotus elise est proche aujourd'hui david
w i3 qui vient de sortir électrique
alors si tu es d'également une voiture
sans ternir vous n'aimez pas ce terme
préféré une voiture accessible aux 16 à
77 ans donc aux personnes aux plus
jeunes mais également aux plus vieux
également aux écolo puisque c'est une
voiture
électrique donc les voitures sans permis
tout de même c'est le cadre d'activités
de jdm depuis 30 ans ce n'est pas une
nouvelle la société et vous visez
également l'export oui tout à fait alors
c'est l'origine de cette voiture
effectivement c'est 1980 avec la
première jdm électrique avec des
batteries à plomb puis après c'est
diversifié alors aujourd'hui on est à 90
% de véhicules qui sont diesel avec des
petits moteurs yanmar lombardini donc
c'est le gros le gros volumes
aujourd'hui des ventes l'année dernière
on devra réaliser près de 800 voitures
vendues dans neuf pays européens qui
sont la suède la norvège la hollande
l'italie le portugal
et des quelques pays européens alors
vous vous souhaitez développer avec ses
véhicules et les véhicules électriques
cela fait quelques années d'ailleurs
quand vous y travaillez nos
téléspectateurs se souviendront
peut-être qu'il y à quelques temps on
vous voyez sur notre chaîne transformez
votre véhicule à moteur thermique en
voiture électrique et vous misez
également sur l'autopartage oui c'est
effectivement là la formule enfin je
pense que depuis vingt ans le monde a
changé le monde a évolué les prises de
conscience en plus en plus importante il
a peut-être qu'une chose qui n'a pas
changé jusqu'à présent c'est vraiment le
monde de l'automobile parce que quand on
vérifie avant les années 1900 comment
les chevaux traverser paris il faut
faire ça une certaine vitesse je pense
que les voitures traversent à peu près à
la même vitesse aujourd'hui le seul
problème c'est que au lieu d'avoir
quelque chose qui conserve qui existent
en environnement on envoie des
particules aujourd'hui à l'extérieur
donc l'idée de rouler à moins de 80 km
heure dans les villes me fait pencher
aujourd'hui sur ce type de concept de
voiture qui me semble plus propice pour
un bon développement et permettent en
plus dans cet environnement grâce à
l'auto partage de pouvoir en plus
partagé cette voiture c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on oriente de plus en
plus vers la voiture électrique qui va
permettre effectivement d'avoir une
voiture assez moderne qui n'existe pas
est une sorte de support de téléphones
portables de smartphones qui permettra
de rendre la voiture encore plus
communicante alors le téléphone portable
c'est là dessus que vous avez anisé vous
avez d'ailleurs façon qu'ils avaient
trouvé le concept pour la twizy pour
permettre l'autopartage et ouvrir les
portes sans clé finalement oui oui on
avait on avait participé au concours
l'epide il ya quelques années où on
avait gagné la médaille d'or de la coupe
de paris avant d'ailleurs que les
véhicules dolorisme se mettent à paris
avec un kit qui permettait effectivement
de transformer des véhicules existants
en véhicule autopartage ou grâce à une
clé box j'étais venu d'ailleurs ici avec
la keybox on avait la possibilité
d'ouvrir les portes de sa voiture avec
un téléphone portable pour accéder à une
québec ce qui s'ouvrait pour donner les
clés aujourd'hui on a fait un pas encore
supplémentaires
georges depuis un peu plus d'un an on a
créé une société qui s'appelle km où
vous dire le nom vient de la keybox est
acquis a repris audition ce concept là
et olivier rossini qui est à la tête de
kembo aujourd'hui participe grandement
au déploiement de ce téléphone portable
qui va permettre maintenant aussi de
démarrer la voiture donc on à
l'ouverture des portes est aussi le
démarrage le démarrage alors on reste
sur twizy vous
et avec qui vous vous développez la
twizy way au delà des frontières de
saint quentin en yvelines on le verra à
mon avis en images elle est accessible
maintenant dans une station de ski oui
oui bah c'est la grande nouveauté on a
fait le test je crois d'ailleurs olivier
rault céline était venu sur votre chaîne
vous présenter effectivement les
prémices le démonstrateur qui ont un
effet sur les 2 alpes là maintenant
c'est chose faite à l'alpe d'huez où
effectivement 24 twizy en ce moment sont
en autopartage à la montagne avec des
équipements et ça c'est la force du
groupe aujourd'hui c'est à dire que adm
est toujours une société avec des
ingénieurs qui innovent ldm est toujours
une société qui fabrique nos innovations
et donc on a transformé les twizy dans
des petits véhicules qui permettent de
porter les skis et de pouvoir en plus
utilisé cette weezy avec le forfait de
ski ce qui permet donc aux gens de la
montagne de pouvoir aller un peu plus
loin en fin de journée que de rester
dans la station pour rappel à ceux qui
ne connaissent pas encore le groupe dans
votre gros vous avez donc jdm ldm adm et
qui mauvais
vous vous développez donc du coup avec
ce système de téléphone également
l'autopartage pour votre nouveau
véhicule au xerox le but c'est également
au fait de rendre accessibles ces
véhicules à l'autopartage oui alors le
but déjà c'est de se dire que vous savez
il ya trois ruptures qui ont marqué
notre monde la première rupture je pense
qu'il ya eu le téléphone avec fils qui
est arrivé après au téléphone sans fil
avec un nokia qui était indétrônable et
puis d'un seul coup on a vu les
smartphones arrivée en 2001 avec une
marque qui n'était pas du tout dans le
téléphone mais qui faisait du service la
deuxième évolution ça a été
effectivement le monde des tableaux de
bord qui était très compliqué et puis
une révolution avec une nouvelle voiture
électrique tesla qui est arrivé avec un
écran plat où on a dû facebook ses
e-mails et où l'ensemble la troisième
révolution aujourd'hui c'est de se dire
que on est en perpétuelle communication
à la maison dans la voiture et au
travail et pour conserver tout ça
aujourd'hui c'est le data services pas
sur le cloud et le cloud c'est google
qui vient d'annoncer qu effectivement il
serait mettre aujourd'hui des voitures
autonome ce que nous faisons déjà depuis
un certain temps au niveau du groupe et
donc cette fracture ou cette rupture ou
cette mutation technologie nous
l'accompagnons en faisant en sorte que
notre jdm soit la première voiture qui
intègre tout de suite une carte sim
c'est au lieu d'avoir un téléphone vous
mettez une carte sim grosso modo dans la
voiture dès la sortie de l'usiné seront
toutes équipées de cartes sim qui
permettront à l'infini d'avoir une sorte
de jdm store pour pouvoir avoir des
applications qui permettront de suivre
sa voiture à distance de d'envoyer des
messages notamment elle sera géolocalisé
en cas de vol on sort aussi ce qui se
passera donc ça permettra effectivement
d'offrir des tas de services en avoir à
modifier par derrière parce que la
voiture aura les pré équipement là on
est prêt par le temps mais je repose de
finir en images avec
votre invention le valet de parking qui
permet du coup de lier un petit peu ces
différentes innovations puisque on peut
donc du coup l'ouvrir avec un téléphone
portable elle se gare toute seule et
elle permet également l'autopartage
puisqu'on pourra l'appeler par téléphone
et elle viendra donc du coup son
chauffeur passé de
d'une façon simple je plais samoa un
distributeur automatique de véhicules
électriques en autopartage ou pas mais
ça devient vraiment une machine qui vous
distribue la voiture quand vous avez
besoin la sortie des gares la sortie des
aéroports la sortie des entreprises
arrêtons de perdre du temps dans les
parkings pour aller effectivement avec
ses sacs quand on sort des des grands
centres commerciaux cela c'est la
voiture qui vient vers vous et vous
l'envié où vous voulez mais en tout cas
merci beaucoup
d'informations dont certaines dans
quelques années se développer ce type de
véhicule on passe tout de suite au
dossier la semaine
le dossier de la semaine est consacrée
aux ressources humaines pour les
entreprises il s'agit d'une vraie
stratégie de développement le regard
qu'on leur porte a bien changé comment
la gestion des ressources humaines s'est
adapté à notre société actuelle à notre
rapport au travail réponse avec notre
dossier la semaine réalisé avec elodie
moines les rh les ressources humaines un
secteur qui n'a pas toujours une bonne
image auprès des salariés et pourtant
les outils rh occupe une place de plus
en plus stratégique dans les entreprises
il y a quelques années la direction des
ressources humaines gérer principalement
les recrutements et l'administration du
personnel mais aujourd'hui elle
représente un des facteurs de
performance de la société autrefois
c'est vrai que la fonction rh consistait
à mettre en application le dispositif
statutaire de nos jours on se dirige de
plus en plus vers une personnalisation
des pratiques rh tenant compte des
spécificités de chaque cible pour
comprendre concrètement comment les
outils rh se sont adaptés nous sommes
allés voir ce qu'il en était dans des
entreprises yvelinoise nous rendons
maintenant chez assystem cette
entreprise internationale spécialisée
dans l'ingénierie et du conseil en
innovation elle emploie 6500 personnes
en france dont 1500 ici à saint quentin
en yvelines et vous allez le voir au
niveau des ressources humaines elle a
une approche assez original nous
retrouvons christelle jacques
responsable du recrutement et de la
diversité
vous allez recruter 1500 personnes oui
tout à fait 1500 personnes 70 % donc en
cdi au niveau national 30 % de ces
places seront en général destiné aux
juniors donc entre 0 et 3 ans
d'expérience alors une fois qu'ils ont
intégré votre entreprise il faut essayer
de motiver et de les garder dix ont
longtemps dans l'entreprise qu'est-ce
qui est mis en place pour ça alors on a
toute une politique de ressources
humaines qui est à destination du
collaborateur il faut qu'il se retrouve
aussi dans l'entreprise dans laquelle il
yves qu' une bonne ambiance que le coup
les valeurs que nous avons sont des
valeurs qui sont partagés de solidarité
de réactivité et de responsabilité la
société propose ainsi des évolutions de
carrière rapide la moyenne d'âge des
salariés n'est que de 35 ans aujourd'hui
on parle beaucoup la génération y qui
est beaucoup moins finalement fidèle aux
entreprises qu auparavant comment du
coup s'attaquer à cette cible la
fonction rh à mon avis est là pour aider
les managers à réussir une meilleure
collaboration intergénérationnelle
les études l'observation que nous
faisons les témoignages que nous
entendons de la part de praticiens nous
montre qu'il y à deux attentes
spécifiques aux gens de la génération y
tout d'abord ce sont des jeunes qui
veulent un feedback continue ils sont
avides de feedback engins de la
génération y n'attendra pas l'entretien
individuel semestriels ou annuels pour
attendre une appréciation de son travail
et ce point est étroitement lié à ce
besoin d'apprentissage et d'acquisition
de nouvelles connaissances le deuxième
point porte sur le management les jeunes
s'attendent en management plus
participatif le jeunes de la génération
y voit en son manager plutôt un tuteur
un mentor que qu'un chef directif
autoritaire chez assystem on tente de
sortir du modèle hiérarchiser d'une
entreprise classique un exemple simple
ici tout le monde se tutoie ça peut
paraître un peu particulier les premiers
jours mais on s'y habitue vite les
personnes sont accessibles et il ya en
général une bonne ambiance donc on a
même fait une vidéo sur cette ambiance
pour montrer comment c'était au sein de
notre société aujourd'hui les jeunes ne
sont pas les seuls privilégiés de
l'entreprise une charte visant
l'équilibré entre vie professionnelle et
vie privée a également été mise en place
pour faciliter le quotidien des parents
pas de réunion après 18h par exemple
enfin pour évoluer un institut de
formation a été créée on a un institut
qui regroupe plusieurs instituts de
formation
l'idée est venue qu'on a beaucoup de
compétences en interne on a beaucoup
d'experts des personnes qui vont partir
à la retraite prochainement et donc du
coup dé transmission de savoir faire et
des expertises à avoir on a des secteurs
qui comme le nucléaire sont en plein
essor depuis maintenant quelques années
du coup à travers ces instituts on a nos
experts qui forment la jeune génération
donc chaque grand coeur d'activité au
sein d'un système à son institut qui
permet de former soit des collaborateurs
d'un autre secteur et qui rentre dans ce
nouveau secteur soit des collaborateurs
qui seraient des nouveaux embauchés au
sein d'un système est d'avoir cette
couleur métiers qui n'ont pas forcément
peut-être à l'école les collaborateurs
restent en moyenne sept ans dans cette
entreprise dans les grandes entreprises
la drh et conseillère du management
c'est un partenaire d'affaires qui est
là pour aider les managers à gérer leur
personnel leurs collaborateurs dans les
petites entreprises rares sont les
structures qui prévoit une entité
spécifique dédiée aux activités rh c'est
surtout le dirigeant qui fait de
l'administration et de la gestion du
personnel il peut être aussi accompagné
d'un directeur administratif et
financier
la politique rh et donc forcément
différente dans des petites structures
nous sommes allés voir ce qu'il en était
chez telle star une entreprise
spécialisée dans les solutions de
pompage
mathieu gilles s'est vu confier la
direction de la société par son père il
ya quatre ans une société dont le
capital est détenu à 100 % par la
famille g la vraie différence entre une
boîte familiale et une autre société
c'est que la direction c'est-à-dire moi
en fait et la famille incarne quelque
chose et puis on est passé d'une gestion
c'est aussi une des difficultés très
patriarcales entre mon père s'en
occupait c'était il y avait moins de
monde dont les gens se connaissent et
mieux c'était un peu plus direct moi
aujourd'hui je dirige 140 personnes je
suis obligé de mettre en place un
certain nombre de règles j'ai embauché
il ya quelques années maintenant une
responsable des ressources humaines qui
m'aident là dessus donc voilà il faut
basculer de ce mode voilà un peu
patriarcal à une gestion un petit peu
plus organiser de ressources humaines
sinon la croissance se fait avec plus de
difficultés les attentes de ses salariés
ont évolué avec la taille de la société
aujourd'hui telle star pour à 140
personnes pour un chiffre d'affaires de
24 millions d'euros quels outils vous
avez mis en place pour attirer tout
d'abord c'est ses salariés alors vous
proposer à nos salariés une mutuelle
leur proposer des tickets restaurant
leur propose un certain nombre davantage
de 13e mois de participation qui sont on
va dire aujourd'hui un peu le standard
dans une boîte de notre taille et en
même temps pouvoir les accompagner de
façon très individuelle tout au long de
leur carrière
via des entretiens annuels via des
contacts réguliers et je dirais avec
leur manager mais aussi avec la
direction aussi avec leur patron j'ai la
prétention de connaître l'ensemble de
mes employés de savoir ce qu'ils font de
leur dire bonjour quasiment tous les
matins donc c'est vraiment le mix entre
les deux et c'est ce qui fait que les
gens au final aime bien rester chez nous
pour ceux qui restent on a on a comme
toutes les sociétés interne aux verts je
dirais un peu un peu obligatoire on a
des gens qui viennent de gros goût mais
qui nous disent mais c'est génial de
travailler chez vous parce que médias -
des portiques parce qu'il ya moins de
pression parce que il ya moins de dire
archi parce que quand on a un problème
on a accès directement à la personne qui
est responsable et dans le côté on a des
gens qui nous disent moi ça me convient
pas j'ai besoin d'être dans une
structure un peu plus grosse beaucoup
plus encadré c'est plus difficile pour
nous de proposer un plan de carrière
extrêmement définit les gens chez
schaettel stars font leur carrière je
dirais il se la font eux mêmes en fait
sarko on sait pas défini à l'avancé
petites et grosses structures ne propose
donc pas les mêmes outils rh mais
mathieu gilles réfléchit à mettre en
place une formation interne au delà de
la taille et le secteur d'activité a
également son influence les usines
miseront plus sur la sécurité au travail
les entreprises technologiques sur
l'investissement créativité de leurs
salariés aujourd'hui la gestion des
ressources humaines a donc pris une
place majeure un véritable atout
compétitif qu'il faut adapter aux
secteurs d'activité à la taille de
l'entreprise ou de l'établissement
public est de plus en plus au profil de
chaque salarié
avant de se quitter noter dans vos
agendas renaat e lle mieux communiquer
pour ces entretiens de recrutement ou
éventuellement d'évaluation s'est
organisée à la cité des métiers ça se
passe le 25 février de 14 à 16 heures
attention il faut s'inscrire merci
d'avoir été avec nous je vous souhaite
une très bonne soirée et je vous donne
rendez vous la semaine prochaine